hello everybody
i'm maurice samuels the director of the
yale program for the study of
anti-semitism
and it's my great pleasure to welcome
you today to the next installment in our
benjamin
and barbara zucker lecture series which
is being co-sponsored today
by the university of california berkeley
our speaker is ethan katz he received
his ba from amherst and his phd
in history from the university of
wisconsin
before moving to berkeley he taught at
the university of cincinnati and he is
now
associate professor of history and
jewish studies
at berkeley where he co-leads an
anti-semitism
education initiative which he recently
founded
a specialist of france and the
francophone world
katz's research interests include jewish
muslim relations
jews and colonial societies holocaust
studies
and the interplay between the religious
and secular and modern jewish life
his first book the burdens of
brotherhood jews and muslims from north
africa to france
published by harvard in 2015 received a
number of prizes
including a national jewish book award
and the j russell major prize of the
american historical association
katz has also co-edited three books uh
these include colonialism and the jews
uh honored last year as a finalist for a
national jewish book award
and most recently a special issue of the
journal jewish history
on jews and muslims in france before and
after charlie hebdo and iber casher
he's now at work on an exciting new book
project
on the jewish underground in algiers
during world war
ii currently entitled freeing the empire
the uprising of jews and anti-semites
that helped win world war
ii and his lecture today draws from
research for this
project so i want to urge all of you to
ask questions to write your questions at
any point you can start writing as soon
as he
starts talking but submit those
questions using the q
a function at the bottom of your screen
please
don't raise your hand um i won't see it
and don't virtually raise your hand
because i won't see that either
and the chat function has been disabled
so the way it's going to work is that um
ethan
is going to uh give his presentation for
about 30 35 minutes
and then we will open it up to your
questions that i will filter from the q
a function so ethan take it away
thank you so much maury uh thank you for
the invitation
and for that kind introduction i'd also
like to thank
uh inescova for all of the arrangements
that were made in setting up
and publicizing the lecture and etta
heber at berkeley for
her work as well i'm going to go ahead
and
share my screen here one moment
okay in the early morning hours
of november 8th 1942 the american and
british armies began operation
torch at that time the largest
amphibious landing in recorded human
history
the invasion saw 110 000 troops in 800
warships and transports
land on a score of beaches spanning
more than 1200 miles of the atlantic and
mediterranean coastlines
the key site for the campaign was north
africa and all involved in the strategic
planning agreed that victory ran through
the rapid seizure of the city of algiers
now it's well known that operation torch
opened a crucial second front in world
war
ii soon chasing the axis forces from
north africa
setting in motion the allied liberation
of southern europe what is far less well
known is that the allied
path into algiers was paved by the work
of an underground movement
in which a band of young jewish liberals
teamed with a group of arch-conservative
military brass and businessmen
over a period of months preceding the
invasion the resistors coordinated their
efforts with the americans
in particular with robert murphy the
special us envoy to the region who
reported directly to president franklin
d roosevelt
in the last days before the invasion the
home of only abu queer
became the headquarters for the
insurgency album care was a prominent
figure in the algerian jewish community
and more broadly respected as a doctor
professor and local political leader
his son who's pictured here on the left
the 22 year old medical student
jose able have been one of the earliest
to organize resistance in algeria
and would assume central importance in
the insurrection
in the wee hours of november 8th the
designated date of the allied landing a
rather
motley group of several hundred students
shop owners doctors lawyers
and a handful of french military
officers managed to take over
nearly all of vichy france's major
institutions in algiers and to place the
regime's key leaders under house arrest
the success of the underground was all
the more remarkable for the numerous
obstacles it faced the insurgents were
ill-equipped only possessing several
hundred level rifles that predated world
war one
and tour buses provided by the americans
in many cases their claim to authority
was thin
they disguised themselves by wearing
armbands with the initials
vp the insignia of a local volunteer
militia
tied to the vichy regime in the days
before the invasion
promised arms from the americans
repeatedly failed to appear
at the appointed time on the night of
november 8th at least one-third of the
young men who had affiliated with the
insurgency
movement did not show up in the midst of
chaos jose able
took charge as various teams of
insurgents fanned out to key points
throughout the city
at a series of locations the same scene
repeated itself
a small group of resistors showed up
wearing the armbands of the local
militia
carrying rifles and in some cases they
did not know how to use and showing
orders for them to relieve the vichy
commanders
unsuspecting the officers on duty turned
over control of each strategic location
to the members of the insurgency yet as
dawn broke there was still no sign of
the americans
they had elected to take a slow and
circuitous path toward algiers
rather than the rapid one originally
promised now vichy had begun to fight
back
joe's able care utilized a blend of ruse
and inspiration
to rally the resistors imploring them
over the radio to hold their posts for
as long as possible
eventually late that day the allies
entered algiers and took control of the
city without firing a shot
before too long they would control the
broader mediterranean
at the time of the invasion north africa
was under the control of the vichy
government
france's authoritarian pro-german regime
that had taken powers shortly after the
french surrendered to the germans in
june 1940.
in october 1940 of its own accord vichy
had abrogated the crimea decree
the act that in 1870 had made nearly all
algerian jews into equal french citizens
the decree had been a turning point in
algerian jewish history
separating jews from their muslim fellow
natives who did not enjoy citizenship
and became racially defined as so-called
indigene
which translated to natives but had a
more negative
connotation and this began a process
whereby algeria's jews
would gradually become deeply attached
to french language and culture
now in october of 1940 with the stroke
of a pen
jews were suddenly demoted to antigen or
colonial subjects themselves
they occupied the same status as muslims
further anti-semitic measures followed
much to the consternation of the jewish
insurgents of november 8
1942 the liberation of algeria by the
allies did not restore jews pre-war
status overnight
instead a new battle began over the
territory's french leadership
and ideological direction jews despite
their central role in the uprising did
not succeed immediately in regaining
their rights
for the first few months following the
landing all the racial laws remained
in place and jews who had lost their
professional position or their property
only recovered them on an individual
basis
it was only in october of 1943 nearly a
year later
that jews in algeria regained their
french citizenship
now scholarship on the algiers
underground and its jewish participants
remains rather limited and to date it
has generally focused on either the
military and political strategy of the
north african campaign in its
aftermath or on the episode as a case of
jewish heroism
soon betrayed by the american invaders
and the french administration
these analyses have left us with little
sense of who the resisters were and what
motivated them
more specifically we are left to wonder
at the curious alliance at the heart of
the story
for the group's ideological diversity
was remarkable
monarchists and communists opponents of
democracy and ardent republicans
and perhaps most strikingly jews and
anti-semites joined together in what
became known as the movement of november
8th
how was this possible in the book i'm
currently writing this is among the
puzzles i'm trying to piece together
and the focus of much of my talk today
will be outlining the participants in
this rebel alliance
and discussing some of the possible
catalysts for their cooperation
that not only seems counterintuitive
today but did at the time as well
i should add that this is very much a
book in progress
and i look forward to your questions and
comments uh as i continue to think about
the issues that i'm discussing today
but before i get to this puzzle we can
only appreciate the history and
significance of the algiers insurrection
by placing it within the broader context
of the holocaust in north africa
and european political culture in
algeria
while central and eastern europe of
course saw the greatest anti-semitic
atrocities during the holocaust
the nearly half million jewelling in
french north africa suffered
significantly as well
many racial laws enacted by vichy were
extended to algeria morocco and tunisia
leading to severe professional quotas
intensive surveillance and more than 100
labor camps
where jewish prisoners were often
singled out for especially harsh
treatment
algeria is particularly significant to
the european story
the territory was in large part and next
to france
since the 19th century and was home to
almost a million european colonial
settlers whose political culture was
steeped in the anti-semitism of the
1930s
by late 1941 most
excuse me most jewish children have been
expelled from the public primary schools
in algeria
most notable and devastating of the
measures taken in algeria however
was vichy's decision in autumn 1940 to
strip
all jews of the french citizenship that
they had enjoyed for 70 years
the story of the resistance also looks
different from the mediterranean's
southern shore what we mostly know about
the french resistance is a classic case
in which history has been written by the
victors
the wartime triumph and post-war legacy
of the gallus and communists
helped to create a narrative that makes
several assumptions
first we imagine that french insurgents
emerged in opposition not only to the
germans
but also to the vichy government in
addition we see the resistance as
comprised of liberals republicans
socialists and communists finally
according to a stubbornly enduring
narrative
on one side stood lazy stunt fighting
virtuously against
nazi and vichy anti-semitism while on
the other side stood anti-semitic
perpetrators and collaborators
the story of the algiers insurgency
problematizes each of these assumptions
the developments that would become the
algiers insurrection gathered steam
across
three geographical nodal points and the
first of these was not algiers
but somewhat surprisingly it was
actually vici
the resort town in the massive central
region of southern france where marshall
felipeten set up the new french
government after the fall of france
in june 1940. as many of you know vichy
was authoritarian anti-republican
traditionalist pro-german and
anti-semitic
it was also as counterintuitive as it
seems an important wellspring of early
resistance
while they remain little known during
the early months following the defeat
numerous vichy officials engaged in a
double game
they remained loyal to marshall payton
but they mistakenly believed that he was
hamstrung by the occupiers
and that they should thus begin to
undertake the work of resistance
that he ultimately supported but could
not do himself and might openly join
someday these were among the group that
a handful of historians of the
occupation in france have in recent
years dubbed
viscisto resistance
the notion of the vishista stone only
really emerged in the aftermath of
revelations in the mid 1990s that then
french president francois mitrond
pictured second from the right in the
photo on the left here
had had affiliated for several years
with the organizations of the far right
and had worked loyally for vichy france
until 1943. this was a major
shocking scandal uh at the time in
france indeed the vista racist
also included many like mitron who
underwent a process of evolution in the
course of the war
from vichy loyalists to full
participants in the organized resistance
the term applies as well to those who
had been members of interwar extreme
right groups but decided
while retaining their ideology to act
against not only the nazis but also the
vichy regime
even as they fiercely opposed the
germans and sought to renew the french
fight against nazism
these men and women often supported much
of vichy's social policy
including regarding jews and this was
the case for several actors in the
algiers insurgency
in order to account for the importance
of the arch conservatives
who were the vicisto and played a
leading role in the insurrection
we have to turn to the second geographic
node in our story
washington washington's eyes and ears in
north africa were substantially those of
us envoy robert murphy
who reported directly to president
franklin d roosevelt
from the moment of the french defeat in
june 1940 the race was on to find
partners in french north africa
who might play a role in an eventual
effort to liberate europe
murphy along with other key american
officials took a decidedly pragmatic
approach in looking
for these partners murphy and his
colleagues long believe that some
version of vichy in fact
might be part of the solution rather
than the problem
eventually the americans became
convinced that general
augie jiro rather than charles de gaulle
the leader of free france in london was
the right man
to lead the resistance shiro was at
heart a proud french patriot who
believed the germans could be defeated
what he sought to overturn was not
vichy's social policies but rather its
decision to collaborate with the germans
jiro himself was unabashedly
anti-semitic the choice of jiro as
leader of the resistance highlights what
would become a key pattern of american
conduct in north africa
a single-minded focus on winning the war
at the expense of ideological
considerations
or deep concern for algeria's jews jiro
stepped into a movement where other
prominent frenchmen from the mainland
were also in key roles
many of whom were equally or more
conservative this was particularly true
of the so-called committee of five
the group of french businessmen and
officers who worked closely with the
insurgents
and the americans and coordinated many
of their efforts
the group included only
a committed monarchist and long-time
member of the axiom francaise
charlemagne's immensely influential
neo-monarchist
anti-democratic ultra-nationalist
political party
for which a virulent anti-semitism was a
central preoccupation
since its founding during the dreyfus
affair dastier was rumored
to have participated in the kagul of
1936-1937
the cagoule was originally a breakaway
from axiom frances
it was an extreme right underground
revolutionary movement
whose long list of avowed enemies and
targets included jews
working closely with italian fascists
the kagu louds stockpiled weapons
assassinated the leftists and planned a
coup d'etat against the fun popular
two other members of the committee of
five jean-li-go and jacques lemaire
dupoy
were confirmed former kagulao rigo used
his closeness to the vichy regime to
foster contacts between certain
officials and the movement in algiers
the mecca du bois admired vichy's
anti-democratic autocratic tendencies
and its arch-conservative national
revolution program
of national renewal and he was deeply
suspicious of communism
both were avowedly anti-gaulist a fourth
member of the committee
colonel a.s van eck actually headed the
chantier de la genes
vici's official scouting organization
meant in large part to serve as a youth
movement that would acquire and help to
spread the values
of the national revolution my next
sought to rally several hundreds
chuntier as troops within the algiers
underground
as the work of daniel lee has shown
recently the chantier in the mainland
did for a time offer protection
to a significant number of jews
nonetheless in november 1941 in a
ministerial memo van
eck made no bones about the fact that he
thought the chantilly in north africa
should not
accept any jewish members at all because
jews he claimed could not acquire the
nationalistic values
of the national revolution in his memoir
of the early years of the resistance
jacques sustained would claim about rigo
and lamechra du bois
and this might be said about a number of
the vicis del rey stone quote
their hostility toward germany was
matched by their hostility toward free
france
a quote free vichy was not a free france
but rather the national revolution
freed from the hitlerian shackles and
protected by washington
this is what they wanted and this is
what they almost got
shustelle's caustic remark hinted at a
deeper truth that we can better
appreciate
in light of the current scholarship on
the vichystel
a key contingent of the insurgency
comprised men who
even as they took great risks and joined
clandestine networks to resume the fight
against the germans
also had links to vichy that continued
to influence their resistance work
now this successful turn of the vicis
del bezier stand would not have been
possible absent their unlikely alliance
with a scrappy group of algerian jews
these jews emerged from what i have
described elsewhere borrowing the
terminology of david sorkin
as an algerian jewish subculture in the
wider european sector of algerian
colonial society
that is even as these jews took french
first names in public spoke primarily
french
in public often saw themselves as
unqualifiedly french
their primary community was made up of
other algerian jewish
individuals groups and institutions this
was reflected in a number of common
characteristics of the jews and the
insurgency
taking us into the third nodal point in
our story these jews tended to cluster
in certain neighborhoods of algiers
with high concentrations of jews we see
marked on this map a few of those places
in algiers as well as scenes from those
neighborhoods on
the left moreover in many
cases large numbers of resistors hailed
from the same extended family
among the abu khao family for example
some 15 siblings cousins and uncles
across two cities
took part in the insurgency beyond
social geography and kinship networks
a high percentage of these jews came
from families that were active
in major jewish organizations
particularly those that sought to fight
anti-semitism
and improve relations with the muslim
and christian populations
these included the major community
political organization the algerian
jewish committee of social studies
or the c-j-a-e-s and the algerian branch
of the largest french anti-racist
organization
the international league against racism
and anti-semitism better known as the
likka
the organizational mission of both the
cjaes and the lipka
made them logical entry points from
which to move into active resistance
during the war
the cjaes defined its goal as quote
keeping vigil
in order that jews free exercises of the
rights of the citizen
neither be violated nor little known the
liquor was an organization founded
precisely to combat anti-semitism
and whose functions by the mid-1930s
included that of having certain members
act as a jewish defense force shortly
after
vichy dissolved the lilika in 1940
jose albuquerque's cousin rafael
pictured here on the left
who had begun attending the lika
meetings a few months earlier in algiers
gathered dispersed members of the
organization and directed them toward
the newly formed
so-called geographs group among the
founders of the geographs group
were emil athlon and entry tem both
former activists
in the recently banned cow
in my research i've identified as many
as three dozen former lika activists who
participated in the insurrection
other examples of the active jewishness
of participants included charity to
local jewish aid organizations or
schools in the years before the war
and the several jews in the underground
who also had a role in creating a
newly self-reliant jewish school system
in the face of vichy's anti-semitic laws
being active in organizations like the
liquor reflected another common element
of
the jews and the insurgency the newly
aggressive politics that defined the
actions and outlook
of many of them one of the
characteristics of a new generation
coming of age in the 1930s
which highlights again the paradoxical
nature of the wartime rebel alliance
was widespread activists excuse me
widespread activism in anti-fascist
politics
so this is extremely common for many of
those who took leading roles in the
insurgency particularly in the era after
the 1934 constantine riots
a new generation of algerian jews joined
groups like the lika and became active
in large numbers in the algerian
communist party
and this marked the beginnings of a key
shift unlike much of the community
establishment of their parents
generation
these jews took a more confrontational
pose gathering arms standing up to
fascists in the street
and even preemptively attacking on
occasion and the clearest echo of this
newly aggressive posture within the
resistance
appeared in the geograph self-defense
group that formed in autumn 1940
and that would supply in time 130 of the
insurgents who fought
on november 8th you see pictured here
the boxer gio glass
for whom the group was named he agreed
to open this space
uh only thinking that it was a space for
physical fitness and training
whereas secretly uh this militia was
preparing itself there
it became a training round for jewish
shock troops who would both prepare to
fight against hitler and to defend
jews and its ranks included 80 so-called
tufts described by resister lucian ades
as muscular daring
fighters they were ready at a moment's
notice to confront the local militias
that regularly attacked
jews new aspirants to the geographic
group were cross were closely screened
if accepted they then took an oath to
fight to the death
for the liberation of france and the
defeat of the germans and specifically
to defend
algerian jews and there was a sense
of this generational shift that was
present for abu qir
father of jose who had agreed to let his
home be
the headquarters for the resistance in
the weeks before the landing when he
recounted
later the story and he spoke about the
activism of
jose and his sister colette ultimately
he explained he had agreed to let them
use his home as a hub
mostly because he feared for their
safety and sought to protect them as any
father would
but he also admired them put the quote
here
he said they received no outside
material help absolutely none and they
all made great personal sacrifices at
various times
i tried to reimburse them they refused i
insisted
they became angry having seen all that
up close i loved them all the more
i was disgusted at the general passivity
the universal spinelessness i had seen
for years
above all since the defeat if i had died
in 1940 or 1941 i would have died in
despair
having seen the work of the boys of
november 8th i was relieved i could die
in peace
they furnished explosive proof that
pessimism should be set aside that they
reside in our youth resources that are
unexpected
immense unlimited
this generation's newly assertive
left-wing politics hardly aligned
i think that's an understatement with
those of the vicis de gracie resistant
that were of course connected very much
to the right
yet with whom they conspired in the
insurgency and indeed
jose albuquera and only dastia de la
vigre understood that their alliance
based on disparate goals could only be
possible
if the movement reached a formal
agreement to avoid politics altogether
while pursuing its common ends the two
men did just that
in summer of 1942 with the understanding
that each group would immediately regain
its freedom of political
action following a successful allied
landing
once again this extreme mixture of
strange bedfellows and pragmatism
defies enduring assumptions about the
ideological stakes of both jewish
and non-jewish resistance i'm going to
stop sharing my screen now because
those are that's the end of my
powerpoint images
so what was it that made such an
alliance however fleeting
possible contemporary political
alignments and historical precedents
weighed heavily against it at the heart
of the alliance was a relationship
between two men who seemed to have
little in common
the young jewish anti-fascists from
algiers jose abuker
and the middle-aged french monarchist
only dastier de la viciri
55 years later in an interview abulker
would put it this way quote
we knew that he was a monarchist and
even probably a camelot du hua
and he referred here to the so-called
king's camelots
the youth organization of the axiom says
that frequently engaged
in protests and violent street
altercations in the 1930s
abu care continued why did i reach an
understanding with him
me a jew 22 years old an anti-fascist
this man had probably cried
death to the jews during protests in the
latin quarter in paris
this comment alluded to the way that
numerous jews on one side and
arch conservatives on the other had been
active in opposing camps in the pitched
ideological struggles of the 1930s
but it also hearkened back to a longer
history wherein jews and monarchists had
hardly mixed well
in modern french history as maurice
samuel's new book the betrayal of the
duchess shows in fact
tensions between monarchists and jews
were crucial to the origins of modern
french anti-semitism
during the 1832 uprising of the
so-called bourbon legitimists that
sought to reclaim the throne from the
more modern early and east branch
simon dutz son of the chief rabbi of
france and a recent convert to
catholicism
played a key role first lutz gained the
confidence of the uprising's leader the
duchess tiberi
and then in exchange for a large war
reward from the french government
he betrayed her dutes rapidly became
dubbed
quote a second judas and was seen as the
very embodiment of all the evils of
modernism
that the legitimists and their
supporters so desperately opposed
more recently in the late 19th century
after mael a wealthy jewish capitalist
had directed the right-wing royalist
newspaper legal hua
eventually becoming an and anti-dry
facade converting to catholicism
and marrying a woman of noble origin at
the age of 60.
maya was heavily criticized by jewish
activists like bernard lazao
for betraying his origins and exploiting
the working class
so there was a great deal of baggage if
you will
weighing down the possibility of close
cooperation between
an ardent monarchist and a visible jew
and yet a series of considerations both
practical and ideological
brought together and dostier and by
extension many around them
on the pragmatic side we have seen that
the u.s state department decided to set
aside concerns about policy and rights
in the short term
in order to prioritize military victory
this meant supporting what became a
coalition of conservative even
anti-semitic forces
and jewish activists since both groups
were ready to help pave the way
for the anglo-american landing algerian
jews meanwhile had already in the
inter-war years
particularly after the murderous
constantine riots of august 1934
ceased to rely as they long had on the
french government
to protect their position in an
exception to yosef haymir
well-known argument about modern jewish
politics
they had moved increasingly from to use
his terms
vertical to horizontal alliances in the
1930s these were largely with reformists
and muslims on the left
but after the shattering events of 1940
the
same jews were equally prepared to team
with forces on the right and a temporary
alliance against a common foe
likewise in his memoir of the insurgency
joseph himself points out
the military that military and business
leaders
looking for a band of rebels had limited
options in algiers
in the 1940s here unlike in france where
jews were a tiny percentage of the
population
jews made up 10 of the french citizens
moreover in cisco for those looking for
allies to fight the germans
jew's particular motivations made them
the surest
bet as historian joanna barrage has
argued political flexibility was more
broadly a hallmark
of the vishistoji stone by 1943 notes
barrage despite their fierce
anti-communism for instance
they had decided to work alongside
communists in order to be accepted
within the broader french resistance the
insurrection of algiers shows that their
pragmatism in fact dated from earlier
and extended even to an alliance with
jews
ideological considerations though were
also important
albuquero's supposition about dostier's
participation in anti-semitic rallies
notwithstanding
dastia's brand of monarchism took a more
moderate position on jews he came from a
family that had supported the monarchy
for generations
and while he retained sympathy for the
more radical neo-monarchism of
into the late 1930s he was more closely
aligned with only
and the primary pretender at this time
to the royal throne
in fact in the days after the american
landing dastier even helped to bring
only two algiers
where he hold him up in his apartment as
he sought to negotiate a monarchic
restoration
american general dwight eisenhower
quickly quashed this idea
the compte perry had repeatedly
condemned the accident frances in the
1930s and sought
to create an alternative strand of
royalism in january 1939 he had even
penned an article in his movement's
newspaper
the cochiae royale where he denounced
anti-semitism in no uncertain terms he
wrote quote
it is certainly abusive to speak of a
jewish peril in france
in particular he highlighted the way
that jews whose families had long
resided
in france should be assumed to be good
citizens
these jews he wrote quote took part as
soldiers
as officers in the national wars they
have mixed their blood with that of the
peasants the workers the bourgeois of
france
they are french and to want to exclude
them from the national community
or even to deny their full rights as
french citizens is to wish to weaken the
country that they have served
and that they should continue to serve
this column was reprinted in the
bulletin
of the federation of jewish societies of
algeria the community's monthly
newsletter
and given the level of involvement of
the abolique with community institutions
it is extremely likely that many members
of the family
and those in the wider milieu of the
insurgency would have read this article
and thus been familiar
with the more progressive turn in
royalists thinking regarding the jews
the mention of jewish soldiers
specifically here was also hardly
incidental
even in an infamous statement where he
embraced marshall peyton and vichy
leading
conservative resister only frenet had
answered the question of who to recruit
to the resistance by saying quote
frenchmen of old extraction to the
exclusion of foreigners
even those who are naturalized and jews
if they really
fought in one of the two world wars a
very high percentage of the jewish
fighters in the algiers insurrection
were veterans of the campaign of 1940
including jose albuquerque himself who
had served as an army medic
i don't kara would later explain his
close cooperation with dostier
in simpler terms quote we had something
in common that the generations of today
no longer are familiar with
and which is called patriotism which was
a sentiment of a force that no one could
doubt but part of what appeared to
underlay this mutual sense of patriotism
was specifically the devotion displayed
on the battlefield by abu kal
his father before him in world war one
and so many of their algerian jewish
comrades
so to conclude the unlikely alliance at
the heart of the november 8th
insurrection
between jews and frequently anti-semitic
arch-conservatives
forces us to rethink our conventional
picture of who resisted and why
during the second world war and the
shoah admittedly
part of our misperception can be laid at
the feet of the post-war ridings of the
leading insurgents themselves
in 1946 when dastier submitted a list of
those who participated in the
insurrection
he depicted himself as their undisputed
leader and while he did include jose
able
he explicitly excluded hundreds of
others
mostly jewish who were now part of a
veterans association of november 8th
which he claimed was not to be confused
with the resistance network itself
likewise albuquero's own memoir while
paying tribute to dostier
spoke about the broader committee of
five in acid terms
calling them a total failure in contrast
to the shock troops he had led
and describing the characteristics of
the sincere vicistel
as quote honorable and ineffective while
mocking the group more generally as by
definition
indecisive and yet nonetheless it was
this rebel alliance that made the
algiers underground at once arguably the
finest
hour of the fight and strategically
speaking the most consequential jewish
resistance movement
of the second world war thank you
thank you ethan for that was really
fascinating
um a story that i did not know much
about and
i'm completely fascinated by it and i
personally have a lot of questions
i would encourage um everyone in the
audience to um please submit
questions using the q a function
we have a bunch mostly from alice kaplan
uh who is
is um uh very eager i know to
um i will ventriloquize her her
questions
but um first of all um
a question just a little background i
think might be
helpful for people listening so at one
point you did mention that
um jews were 10 of the population
of of algiers and i i think um
that might surprise people so if you
could say a little bit more about the
demographics
um in algeria uh and especially in the
cities and also
bringing in muslims and the relative
population
yeah um so i mean algeria broadly
uh had six million some muslims at this
time
roughly a million french settlers and
120
000 or so uh jews um so
they are 10 of the french citizens
broadly speaking in algeria it so
happens that algiers
is substantially a european city in many
ways
by the 1930s uh that is almost 70
of the inhabitants are either settlers
or
jews um i think it's about nine percent
jewish
uh 60 settler 30 muslim
um so uh yeah i mean the the
demographics are such that jews are i
mean
a whole other piece of the story uh is
that jews are seeking to
regain of course a position of equal
citizenship and they are
fighting off the prospect of nazism but
they are
also you know essentially fighting to
recover what remains a privileged
position in colonial society
there are extensive debates about
what jews should do with regard to that
very question in the period
after the landing particularly because
it takes so long for citizenship to be
restored and there is
pressure from certain muslim allies for
them to pursue
equal citizenship for all rather than
simply for themselves
um happy to speak more about those okay
um
all right so here's uh one of alice's
questions so all these
vichy guys um had they ever been in
algeria before um were they
thinking about algeria and france um and
the anti-semites on the far
right on the ground in algeria um were
they
much more extreme than the vichy guys
um were they like you know saline level
anti-semites
um great questions so i mean most of
these guys had not been in algeria
before i mean
certainly not the people in the
committee at five they go there i mean
uh
in many cases they go there already in
1940 and like
you you can read conflicting accounts of
some of their motivations like lemeko du
bois is this
super successful businessman and some
people think that he was very cynical in
his
you know connections to the americans
and the committee of five
other people have more charitable
interpretations of him as a patriot
um but there's a series of business
interests that lead certain people
there in some cases people go there
because
um they are compromised uh dossier was
in a resistance network in france proper
and they escaped
uh to algeria um but basically i mean
i shouldn't say that they've never been
i can't say whether they ever visited
algeria previously right
but they have no particular history or
connection
uh to algeria so yes i mean by and large
i would say that
these folks are anti-semitism is less
central for them
than it is for you know sort of the
ultras of the settler classes
um which alice you know at least as much
about as i do
um and you know anti-semitism was really
central to their political culture uh
you know clearly there's a calculus that
goes on i try to
explain some of that calculus in my talk
where it's not that
most of these folks who are the
vegetables don't are necessarily
that positively disposed toward jews but
they are more focused on
you know re-igniting the war against the
germans and
we have to keep in mind i mean once we
have that agreement in
the summer of 1942 between dossier and
above it's explicit
that this is for a finite period of time
i mean they they can it's always
easier to work with someone who you
aren't really disagree with
when you know you're going to have a
chance to hash out those disagreements
later so i think that's crucial as well
um
yeah um so i wanted to probe a little
bit more
about the vichy um resistance
um guys and so you know i listening to
it i
i couldn't help thinking not to you know
presentize
but i couldn't help thinking about like
the lincoln project
you know and different i mean so what
first of all like you know what is
really i mean is it about
um patriotism is it just about like this
idea that like how can you
side with you know the invader the enemy
and if so like what does take them so
long
you know like you know just like when do
they start to
resist i mean you know mito it's not
until 1943
so is that how much of that is waiting
to see which way the
wind was blowing you know which way the
war would go good questions i mean
they're not one group right those that
have been put under this rubric by
uh historians in recent years so there
are those who actually
are very early to the game in a way that
is shocking to us today because the way
that we've aligned the extreme right of
the 30s
with arden vichyism in the 40s but some
of those folks
in the early months are already saying
well the marshall can't resist we got to
do it for him
and and so some of them are not at all
late covers then you have people like
miton who evolve in some way whether you
want to say that evolution is purely
kind of cynical and self-serving or
whatever you want to say that they
you know realize i mean there there
are certainly folks also who are
loyalists ceviche
without being active resistors
partly because they assume the marshal
is acting on their behalf
and they come to conclude over time that
he is not and they then become
disillusioned with the regime and become
uh resisters
um but you know i think patriotism is
the heart of it i mean i think
that you know they're they're they're
people who
just feel very they feel very strong
against the germans
they feel ultimately like they have to
defend france
and that's sort of their kind of
singular focus
uh in the in the early months there and
in a way
you know it maybe isn't that surprising
on reflection that some of the same
extreme right guys from the 30s
are some of the earliest to want to
resist within the vichy circles because
they're used to being active in kind of
radical politics and their radical
politics has its own kind of
ardent patriotic nationalism attached to
it already before the world
great okay so questions
i'm i'm seeing here about um muslims and
about
um so if you could say a little bit more
about
muslim resistance here and also a
question
from someone in the audience who wants
you to clarify the use of the term
muslim so are you referring to
a mostly arabized elite or the amazigh
communities or both
and yeah and if you could say more about
their
role in this resistance yeah so i mean
the role of muslims and i
i would use that term to describe just
as i would
in a parallel way to the way that i
would use the term jews and i talked a
little bit
about this in my first book i mean i i
think
there were there were and are many ways
to be in some way connected to
muslimness for some people that is islam
as a religion and for other people it's
much more cultural
and that certainly was true in algeria
uh the category of muslim was racialized
by the french administration
uh such that it did not distinguish
between uh religious
practice or lack of practice at all it
was all based on descent
um but the reality was a very large
spectrum so
to me um yeah i mean i there were
various
muslim political groups and we can talk
a little bit more about that
the there were very few muslims in this
resistance movement
if we want to talk about some resistors
during the war the two most
common avenues are aligning with the
algerian communist party
and then joining the liberation armies
uh as they begin to fight their way
uh up into france right that's the vast
majority of muslim algerians who
join the resistance in some form but uh
there are interesting exceptions and the
most interesting i have a whole chapter
about him in the book
is a man named muhammad abdulaziz
who is very closely aligned with a
certain movement
uh in algeria led by ferhat abbas which
is sort of a reformist movement that is
increasingly
moving toward nationalism and casus is
actually the primary author of a famous
document from during the war
uh the manifest of the algerian people
which comes out in 1943 um in march 1943
uh and in that manifest it actually
says given the repeal of the crimea
decree
algerian muslims are led to wonder if
french citizenship
is worth much less than it would be to
be an algerian citizen
um so there are certain muslims like
that who actually talk
very actively about sort of the
connection between what goes on with
jews during the war
and how they are looking for new
political alignments including an
alliance as they referred to
between muslims and jews to fight for uh
equal rights
um and there are a handful of other
muslims who are referred to
in various accounts of the uprising uh
who participate in different groups for
sure
um but there were also those in the
movement who were worried about the
intensity of
access propaganda vis-a-vis muslims and
therefore were hesitant
to invite muslims to join uh i think
broadly speaking
you know the this was ultimately a
fight to throw off the germans and for
many jews to regain their citizenship
uh it wasn't a fight that necessarily
clearly implicated
uh muslim political activists uh for
some of the reasons i've already said
okay great so here's a question from
david sorkin
um he says that uh vichy's
jewish statutes of 1941 included
exemptions for jews who had fought in
either world war
or whose families had been in france for
five generations
so in what sense could you say that the
monarchist reactionary figures in the
uprising
are actually acting in line with a
certain understanding of vc policy
yeah uh great question as usual thank
you david um
so yeah i mean i i actually thought of
mentioning that
um clearly there you know there's a
broader way in which
military service is honored by vichy
including to a significant extent for
jews
um you have all these petitions tavishi
uh
that many of us you know have seen from
right after
uh the first anti-jewish statute where
people say you know my
husband or my father served in world war
one and you should make an exception for
him now
while most of those are not honored um
it's a reflection partly already of sort
of the the cultural ethos around
wartime service uh and then uh as david
said there are these exemptions in 1941
so yeah i mean i think that
um i think that it does reflect that i
think
um you know one of the other things i
talk about in the book
is that a kind of effort to regain
manhood is one of the things that goes
on in
this jewish insurgency and
you have you know you saw briefly the
images there you have a boxing rink
as the center for the largest force
within the insurgency uh you have like
famous boxers coming through there you
have fencing which
however strange may seem to us today was
very strongly associated
with european manhood at this time and
and jews had been disproportionately
participating
in fencing for decades he had a lot of
fencing competitions he had
jewish finalists who were in the fencing
competitions in algeria in the early 40s
despite the opposition of anti-semites
she had all this sort of hyper-masculine
energy and many of these people
were veterans as they said of the
campaign in 1940 so i in some ways i
think
all of this is kind of connected uh that
you know their their effort to reclaim
masculinity comes partly in the form of
joining a resistance group and
they are more palatable
to certain rightists because of the fact
that they connect to
you know military background military
culture
um so to follow up on that question um
there's
all this you know you're describing this
sort of masculine energy it's the story
about reclaiming
masculine identity but what about women
in in these resistance groups you
mentioned
colette the sister of jose i think but
um are were there other women involved
there were other women and collette
herself
is fascinating and um actually i'm
starting the book with colette because
she she
she wrote a five volume memoir of her
childhood
uh she later became a very kind of um
illustrious uh sort of healer through
uh psychological work uh in israel um
and so she is deeply spiritual person
and that's part of what punctuates her
memoir but she also
shows how much she felt the burden of
her family's history i didn't have time
to get into it here but her family
had this kind of rabbinic dynasty in its
history
it had then all these people who'd been
like the first jew to practice medicine
in algiers
people who were enormously successful in
secular colonial society
and so she she hears things from family
and she says things like i understood
that i
would be the one in my generation to
help save the jewish people maybe to
save the world
um so so she's fascinating and she plays
a really important role i mean her
father also describes how she kept
everything together
in the house when everything's buzzing
and there's a million people coming
through
and she's basically you know keeping all
the trains running
uh there are and there are several other
women who maybe we would say have
comparable roles
uh the wife of amy lachlan she like
there's accounts about how she's making
food for all of these people on the
night of the uprising and she's hiding
guns in different places in the house
um it's clearly a small number of women
uh who participate and we even have an
account of uh
one sort of altercation a little bit on
the night of the uprising where
certain male resistors don't want women
taking part
which i think reinforces the sense of a
kind of hyper-masculine
identity for certain segments um but
there were women
who played important roles certainly
particularly uh coletta double kill
great okay another question from alice
kaplan um she's wondering
what you have to say about um
the reluctance of the allies to cancel
the abrogation of the crimea decree
so the jews had to wait for months to
get their citizenship back
how do we explain that is that american
anti-semitism at work or is it the fault
of the french what
what well i mean it's it's a complex
story
um you know i think the americans were
persuaded
and robert murphy writes about this in
his memoir in ways that are frankly
embarrassing at this point but
um he he felt very strongly um
that you know the americans were very
worried that there would be a lot of
muslim anger
if jewish citizenship was restored uh
there is intense lobbying
from the american jewish community that
takes place and that ultimately has a
significant impact
um you know and people are miffed and
murphy says they didn't understand
how everything was so different in north
africa north african jews are different
with african societies different um but
you know there
definitely were people who were
persuaded that jewish muslim
enmity was you know primordial
and that if jews were given back their
citizenship despite the fact that then
you know jews produce letters right from
like leading muslim
city councilors and you know figures
saying you know we didn't have any joy
about the uh abrogation of the crimea
decree and that that's not something we
celebrated
uh you know at all uh so but but
you know that so that's clearly a factor
then you i think
have folks who never i mean you have a
significant segment of algerian colonial
society
that had been campaigning for the
immigration of the criminal decree for
70 years
uh and so was deeply invested in that
and
you know to some extent uh people like
auntie jiro
who's the governor general uh for a
while uh after the landing
you know they are kind of responding to
the pressure from those folks and
and some of those folks and some of the
other vichy officials are also saying
there'll be a civil war between the jews
and the muslims so there's a lot
of that but i also think that the story
i told today
is an important ingredient that is the
viscista resistance
are basically like the slates wiped
clean
in november 1942. they
and many of their supporters want to
kind of
rechart what colonial algeria looks like
jews are fighting for a different vision
of colonial algeria that aligns with
their republican judaism
uh and so it's not shocking in that way
that
given that they had no ideological
consensus that these two visions were so
opposed
it's not shocking that it took
effectively months to hash that out
and it's it's inseparable from the
struggle between the jihadist forces and
the
gaulis forces in algeria in 1943.
great okay i'm going to ask a selfish
question here and i wanted to
yeah thank you for for uh mentioning my
book and i
so i was very interested you know i'm
very interested in
how anti-semitism becomes a key part of
right-wing ideology in france and so you
know part of what i was
interested in was looking at you know a
possible origin point for that or you
know one of
the possible origin points but you know
we know that like
something um you know we normally think
of world war
ii is sort of the culmination of that
right of vichy is
the culmination the the you know it's
the revenge on
on for dreyfus and you know they're able
to enact you know to really
make anti-semitism a part of state
policy
but you're kind of giving this other
possible other
way to see it and that it maybe it's the
culmination but it's also
uh things go over the hill and it's
maybe also the end or an
end point for that i don't know how do
you how do you see that
you know in um because it's true that
anti-semitism
stops being a kind of he you know
the key part of right-wing ideology
after world war ii partly
because it's discredited by hitler but
maybe there's also
something else going on too well i mean
so i'm still learning a lot about
monarchists in um 20th century france um
an understudied subject um for sure but
what i can
what i've gathered is you know you have
the axiom frances which is this
neo-monarchist organization but of
course they attract
many folks who are not monarchists per
se not the dossier style of monarchs
where like
your father and your grandfather and
great grandfather were monarchs for
generations but people who are basically
interested in right-wing radical
politics and charlemagne is arguably the
most influential
you know right-wing radical thinker uh
in 20th century france
so that's it like a different brand of
monarchism but it becomes
discredited effectively by a lot of the
traditional monarchs by the 20s and 30s
right
they were announced by the holy see i
think in 1927
and then they're renounced by mohi uh in
the mid-30s and we should point out i
mean
it's a complicated history but because
the bourbons
uh the legitimists who are traditionally
the more conservative ones
were stuck as it were with a spanish
line from the 1880s
already becomes the de facto pretender
kind of for everybody even though he's
from the oleonese branch
but perhaps the consequence of that is
that the early on these always more
moderate
um end up you know you know he ends up
sort of pushing things in a more
moderate direction um
yeah i mean i think the i think as
anti-sem
i think we could say that as
anti-semitism anti-semitism becomes
radicalized
in the 30s and early 40s it becomes
much more uncomfortable for certain
monarchies who are more traditionalists
yeah okay good that's super interesting
okay uh we're almost out of time
but uh i want to ask one other um
question about um why
more algerian jews who were
expelled from their schools in 1940 you
know
faced all these anti-semitic
persecutions why didn't moore
side with the fln in the 50s
um what what do you think how do you
explain that
great question right it's a sort of a 64
thousand dollar question about
algerian history um yeah i mean i think
that in some ways there's a parallel
between
you know if you will uh 1900
in the french mainland where the dreyfus
affair is almost forgotten and
seen as okay the republic works
eventually
dreyfus uh was pardoned and then of
course he was exonerated in 1906.
um there's a parallel in some ways
between that and and 1945
in algeria i mean to some extent in the
french mainland as well
but you know basically the the vichy
years are in a way i mean they're not
entirely forgotten
and so you have the attempt of the fln
during the 50s repeatedly to invoke the
vichy years and say you know the same
people
who are advocating for colonialism are
the ones who
you know uh took away your citizenship
and treated you horribly then and we
were your
you know we were in solidarity with you
um but
in in a certain way it's like the jews
basically just
you know kind of wanna paper that over
and think that like the real france
was the france that restored their
rights um
and they just you know they also see
themselves they articulate
they see themselves as so frenchified by
the 50s that in a way it's almost like
there's no going back
so they buy into the gallus myth in a
sense and then
you know you think of the resistors or
the resistance no no no the
the post-war gallus myth yes of that
everyone had resisted that that wasn't
the real
france that had done this to them and
and yeah but i think also they just
you know they they see themselves as
products of a
process of successful emancipation and
frenchification
and they they see muslims as like on the
same track
they hope just several steps behind
and they kind of carry that vision
through to the end
all right well we are unfortunately out
of time
but i want to thank you for this really
enlightening
and just fascinating presentation and
thanks for
sharing it and co-hosting this this
event with us so
uh we're really looking forward to the
book so uh i know everyone else is
applauding at home but i'm
finding you for me thanks for all the
questions yeah